i'll tell you this about living in new
york there's all there's all this
culture and stuff and there's this
pressure to absorb it but i'm telling
you right now i've decided something i'm
29 years old everybody and i'm done
pretending i like the museum
i don't like it
i'm a grown man
wanna people still there's all this
press you want a museum yeah yeah yeah
you do yeah walk around all day yeah
all day
just meandering aimlessly
looking at stuff being quiet stuff i
don't understand yeah yeah be quiet yeah
yeah i'll have to pee the whole time
yeah
yeah i'll be exhausted at the end yeah
yeah saturday saturday
yeah yeah all day no
i don't want to go i'm a grown man i
don't have to go i'm not going i don't
care about the museum i only care that
people think i'm the kind of guy who
goes to museums
that's all i care about i go to the met
i get that little pin i forget to take
it off all week i'm like this
yeah i was at the museum
i was quiet and i sketched and i got it
whatever it is grown-ups are doing
that's what i did
but that's not what i'm doing i'm in a
museum i'm not looking at a painting to
appreciate it i'm staring at it trying
to figure out how long is appropriate to
look at it
so when i walk away the other people in
the room aren't like that guy didn't get
it at all
so i just make this video
but up top i'm just like
cheerios
it's not even a song
just picture a black man in a white
tuxedo playing the piano going have him
for breakfast to lunch you decide not
even a jingle
but my face is saying another bridge
over lily pads well done claude
seriously when did that get old for
monet you're like at the unveiling just
like
voila
bridge over lily pads 803.
boom monet
you know you're allowed to do nudes
right
do anything else
but when i find the name brands because
i'm stupid in the museum i like them
more i found the monets instantly i was
like oh these are the good ones
these are the people the ones people
will ask me if i saw i'll buy magnetic
representations of these
to prove that i wasted my day here
steering them loved them found my
favorite one looked down wasn't monet it
was manet
instantly didn't like it
it's like this guy mayonnaise
it's like when you're driving in your
car and you really like a song until you
find out it was maroon 5.
whatever i'm cooler than that